jamais depuis sa création le cinéma
n'aura été plongés dans une taie
l'obscurité
pas l'obscurité réconfortante des
paysans exaltante des salles de cinéma
pas cette obscurité qu'on aime tant
parce qu elle nous sort de nos vis de
nous mêmes et nous rassemble mais
d'obscurité d'une lumière éteinte
mon porte close un rendez vous manqué il
ya eu les choses qu'on dit les choses
qu'on fait et toutes celles qu'on peut
plus faire le temps d'une éclaircie dans
les cévennes
on s'est réjoui de dire adieu aux cons
et pour autant on a tous hâte d'effacer
l'historique de 2020 et de retrouver
notre adn
je ne sais pas si le cinéma vous a
manqué mais vous vous nous avez manqué
terriblement douloureuse
et
est perdu les 46e cérémonie des césar
sera l'occasion de célébrer un cinéma
durement touchée mais debout vivant mais
un patient alors oui on sera peut-être
un peu moins légers on rira peut-être un
peu moins que d'habitude nom sera là en
sang
à
j'ai put est en marche la 46e cérémonie
des césar c'est le vendredi 12 mars à
21h en clair en direct et en exclusivité
sur canal+
[Applaudissements]
ça je détruis tout pour que ceux ci
seraient tous